Các bạn có thể hệ số ca nhân với bạn giả đất, ám dụng cho các trường hợp giáo đất, cho thế đất, chuyển một lịch sử dụng công nhận của những sự dụng đất.
Các bạn tình mới chỉ làm tăng tiền sử dụng đất, lối với các dự án đầu tư có hệ số sự dụng đất theo ký hoạt từ 1 lần trở lên.
Còn các hộ ra đến các nhân chuyển một lịch sản đất ở và không phải đề đầu tư thì không tôn thêm tiền sử dụng đất sau với bạn giả đất hiện nay.
Cứ định của Ui Bán nền dật thành phố, cũng như gió ám các trường hợp không ám dụng bản giả đất trong đó,
cho sau trường hợp sẽ xác định giả đất tụ thể.
Bà gồm tình tiền bối thường khi nhắn nước thu hợi đất, tình tiền sử dụng đất, tiền thơi đất khi ra hàng sử dụng đất,
điều trình thơi hàng sử dụng đất, điều trình quy hoạt xây dụng chí tiền, cho phép trình hình thức sử dụng đất,
sắc định giả khởi điểm để nấu giả quyền sử dụng đất khi nhắn nước giả đất, cho thơi đất,
tình giả chỉ quyền sử dụng đất khi câu phần hoạt giành nghiệp nhắn nước theo quy định của phá luật về câu phần hoạt.
Tình tiền thơi đất khi nhắn nước cho phép đất, tuy tiền thơi đất, một lần cho cả thời gian thơi chứ trường hợp thông qua đổ giả quyền sử dụng đất.
Tình tiền sử dụng đất, lối với tổ chức khi nhắn nước gử dụng đất, có tuy tiền sử dụng đất,
không đổ giả quyền sử dụng đất, không đổ thầu lợi cho nhắn đổ tư, thực hiện dự án có sử dụng đất,
giáo đất có tuy tiền sử dụng đất cho nhắn đổ tư, chúng tao phóc tổ chức kinh tế, gió nhắn đổ tư, chúng tao thành lập,
thực hiện dự án có sử dụng đất, không nhắn quyền sử dụng đất,
cho phép trên mục địch sử dụng đất, mà phá nhau tiền sử dụng đất.